Let's go to our caller from oh, I don't know,
there's so many people.
Oh, you know what?
Let's go to Terry from Newton.
Terry from Newton here in town.
Terry, what's going on?
Hi, David.
How's everything going?
Good.
So I just wanted to call in because there's
been a lot of talk about the early exit polls.
So as you saw, like in Massachusetts alone,
the exit polls said that Bernie was going
to win with about 30 percent of the vote,
but it turned out it actually was Biden who
won with, I think, about 32 percent.
Yes.
And as a result, there's been a lot of talk
about it.
Some people, I think, are, you know, confused.
And probably it was a lot like what happened
in 2016 where some of the early exit polls
said Hillary would win states that she ended
up not winning.
But then there's also other people like unredacted
tonight that have gotten really in-depth and
said there's like some like rigging of the
vote.
And I just want to know, what's your take
on this was like?
Is it just a bad example of, you know, exit
polling and the fact that we need to, like,
really review how we do it?
Or is it more like something sinister is going
on in Bernie needs to be more aggressive about
it.
Listen here.
Here's here's the thing.
So the big picture.
With the exception of Donald Trump in 2016,
it's always you've got the people who lose
who say that.
It was it was rigged in some way.
Trump said it was rigged despite the fact
that he won.
He insists that he didn't actually lose to
Hillary by 3 million votes.
That's kind of a special case.
I at this point can't make the case in good
faith that the exit polls are definitive.
Exit poll discrepancies are definitive evidence
that there was vote tampering, voter machine
tampering or whatever the case may be.
When you look nationally, I don't know if
it's two or 2.1 or 2.2 million votes.
Biden is crushing Bernie in the popular vote
and these margins that are being looked at
when it is proportional allocation of delegates.
This is the really important thing.
It's not it's not all or nothing.
When you look at some of these discrepancies,
even if you can make the case, as I've seen
it made, that there is like a four point swing,
a five point swing, that doesn't really make
sense.
You'd say Biden would still be winning by
a slightly smaller margin.
So I don't I'm not saying that to dispute
or confirm any particular theory.
But what I'm saying is I've not seen and I'm
willing to have my mind changed.
I've not seen anything that I would call sort
of a remotely definitive evidence that vote
tampering is what explains Joe Biden winning
by 2.2 million votes nationally.
Oh.
That sounds about right.
Because there's been people who have been
like throwing that around in redacted tonight,
like they add this guy, Khaled, who's apparently
some expert in elections, although I don't
if I asked like people, like professors and
authors, they probably would strongly disagree
with that.
It's just I'm just worried because, you know,
there's some people who are like tried to
use that as like a pretext that, you know,
saying that Progressive's can't win.
And I think it's tough because, you know,
especially like there's a lot of like voters
who birdee of energized, who don't trust the
electoral process to begin with.
And if they have this feeling that basically
everything's going to be rigged against them
and like other like Bernie crats, then they're
show we're not going to vote on November whether.
Absolutely right.
Yeah.
That's not a program I'm familiar with.
And I wouldn't be able to speak to what they've
said.
But certainly the rhetoric you're describing
will will help Trump and Maydan.
You know, some people may be okay with that.
It's just a it's a it's a strategy disagreement.
It's a it's just a disagreement is all it
is, you know.
Yeah.
Well, I think know very much for answering
my question, David.
My pleasure.
What are you.
Yep.
All right.
Wish you would see this.
Best of luck during this crisis.
Likewise.
Absolutely.
Terry, great to hear from Terry Newton.
That does it for calls today, as always.
I apologize.
I am not able to meet the full demand of the
phone calls that come in, but we will, of
course, take your calls again.